im zuge der ausbildung der militärpilot
wird für unsere hubschrauber piloten
auch der hochgebirgsland lehrgang
durchgeführt der hochgebirgsland der
lehrgang ist nun auf der einen seite
einen ausbildungsgang für unsere
angestellten militärhubschrauber piloten
aber auch auf der anderen seite eine
gute trainingsmöglichkeit für unsere
erfahrenen piloten die auf einen
hubschrauber systemen wie zb den black
hawk die a b 212 diallo a 3 und die a 58
eingesetzt werden
unsere flugschüler internen dabei
landungen im hochgebirge sicher
durchführen zu können dies bei allen
wetterbedingungen im sommer wie winter
bei tag und bei nacht und bei allen
möglichen geländeformen und ich mir hier
haben wir ganz andere verhältnisse als
er unten im tal die windströmungen sind
intensiver aber auch die luftdichte
verändert sich markant im vergleich zu
unseren 500 höhenmeter wo wir jetzt
ziehen währenddessen dich im forum
einen unteren daten eingestellt
stellwerk verwenden muss muss ich im
hochgebirge was doppelt so viel an
meinen leistungs hebel ziehen und das
muss ich regelmäßig trainieren weil das
ein handwerk ist dass man nun auch
ersten kampf bei denen es auch
regelmäßig machen
was ist nun der nutzer von diesen
hochgebirge lehrgang dieser
hochgebirgsland der lehrgang befähigt
alle unsere hubschrauber piloten für
eine sichere flug durchführung im
hochgebirge damit kann sichergestellt
werden dass einerseits militärische
einsätze zum beispiel zu unterstützung
von bodentruppen wie zb gebirgsjägern
mit lufttransport luftaufklärung oder
feuer unterstützung aus der luft
unterstützt werden können aber auch
andererseits assistenzeinsätze geleistet
werden können wie zb bei der suche nach
vermissten zu unterstützen oder auch zb
bei der evakuierung von zivilpersonen
von defekten schienen lagen wie wir es
in der letzten woche hatten